1918 in the first world war is finally
over
as punishment for losing germany's two
wartime allies the austro-hungarian and
ottoman empires were carved up shortly
afterwards the pressures of defeat
plunged germany into chaos and as a
result the kaiser abdicated
revolution and revolution were the order
of the day and in the small town of
weimar berlin was too dangerous
the weimar republic was declared the
next year the allies signed the treaty
of versailles which dictated the terms
of allied victory this territory was
lost and the rhineland was occupied by
the allies
germany further had to reduce its
military massively pay war reparations
and also had to accept almost full
responsibility for the war's outbreak
so this new weimar republic is one of
the most democratic nations in the world
at that point
suffrage was granted to everyone over
the age of 20 including women
the german people could vote on two
aspects of the national government
every seven years they voted on a
president who presided over the german
parliament the reichstag
every four years people would vote for
political parties in national elections
for the reichstag via a system known as
proportional representation
whereby the percentage of votes
nationally dictated the percentage of
seats in the reichstag the president
could call elections whenever he felt
and also had the important job of
appointing the chancellor who ran the
government and could propose laws
these laws had to be passed by a
majority vote in the reichstag and since
no party ever got 50
of the seats that meant the parties
would have to cooperate no
democracy did not guarantee harmony and
there was numerous attempts at
revolutions such as the quickly aborted
socialist republic of bavaria
and the 1920 revolution led by dr
wolfgang capp
capp seized berlin and the german army
refused to attack him because there was
a strong belief that germany had only
lost the war due to political betrayal
cap's revolution was only ended by a
general strike which ground the country
to a halt
this turmoil did not help the german
economy and eventually germany missed a
war payment
the french wished to punish the germans
for this whereas the british wanted
leniency the french government decided
that if the germans would not pay them
then they'd simply take the money
instead and in 1923 the french occupied
the heavily industrialized region of the
roe
the reason for this was that german
reparations could be paid in raw
materials many of which were produced
there
another way that german reparations
could be paid was in foreign currencies
which were paid for by printing more
paper marks
this created the hyper-inflation that
the weimar republic is famous for
for example in january 1923 a loaf of
bread cost 163 marks and in early
november in 1923
the same loaf of bread cost over 75
billion marks
in november 1923 another attempted
revolution occurred in munich led by a
certain adolf hitler and undertaken by
the sa the military arm of the national
socialist german workers party better
known as the nazi party this revolution
failed when other nationalist
politicians refused to help hitler and
the army was called in hitler was
wounded and arrested shortly afterwards
it was imprisoned
that hitler dictated his autobiography
mein kampf which became the bedrock of
nazi ideology all of this would make it
seem like the weimar republic was about
to immediately collapse but it managed
to survive thanks to the intervention of
two specific individuals
gustav stresserman who helped to repair
relations with france and charles dawes
an american who would later become vice
president who helped to relieve some of
germany's economic problems
germany's repayments were lowered the
french agreed to leave the rule and
america agreed to loan germany money
which created a strong economic link
between the two countries
so then the great depression struck
tanking the u.s economy and dragging
germany's down with it paul von
hindenburg the president of germany at
the time failed to get the reichstag to
agree on a response or
anything as a result he had to invoke
article 48 which allowed the president
to pass laws about the approval of the
reichstag in times of
emergency the biggest problem with
article 48 was that there was no
definition of an emergency meaning it
was open to abuse
the german people turned to different
political parties to fix the problems
some chose communism whereas others
placed their faith in the national
socialists the nazis believed that the
german-speaking peoples should be united
in a single state they argued that
communists and the jews were the enemies
of the german people and as such had to
be removed the nazis were popular
because they wished to disregard the
treaty of versailles which many germans
considered insulting
they also wish to limit any foreign
involvement in german affairs by
limiting the rights and numbers of
foreigners in germany
another reason was people's anger with
the continuing economic crises which
they were desperate to end
a series of elections led to a massive
increase in the number of seats held by
the nazis and by 1932 they were the
largest party by far
after continuously coming first hitler
asked president hindenburg to be made
chancellor which he refused several
times because they were worried that
hitler would overthrow the government
yet eventually after the nazi's
continuous victories and elections
hindenburg agreed to give him the job in
january 1933 so hitler immediately began
working to overthrow the government
a fire started in the reichstag by a
young dutch communist was used by hitler
to paint all communists as the enemies
of germany
hindenburg under pressure from hitler
issued the reichstag fire decree and the
reichstug passed the enabling act which
suspended many civil liberties and made
hitler the de facto dictator of germany
these were passed mainly because the
opposing communist parties were outlawed
and that the vote was being held in a
building filled with armed members
of the sa over the next few months
hitler established the secret police the
gestapo in order to help sure up his
position
he outlawed trade unions as they were
seen as breeding grounds for communists
and in july he abolished all other
political parties in 1934 hitler ordered
the ss
another paramilitary group and the
gestapo to eliminate his enemies which
included the head of the essay ernst's
room in an event known as the night of
the long knives
this was mainly because hitler felt that
the sa was the only force that could
stop him shortly after this purge
president hindenburg died and hitler
assumed the role of president as well as
that of the chancellor he declared
himself the fuhrer of germany and using
article 48 create a single-party
dictatorship the lives of germans
changed massively under the new nazi
regime the media was brought under the
control of joseph goebbels the minister
for propaganda
heinrich himmler was placed in command
of the gestapo and the ss who were
ordered to crack down on anyone who
disagreed with the nazi government
germans for the most part accepted
having less freedoms in return for a
higher standard of living and because
the nazis had ended the chaos from the
decade before they took
power the nazi government established
the german labor front which was like a
trade union except without the
representation
the nazis also established the strength
through joy program which was designed
to keep workers happy it even helped to
produce class barriers by making
vacations clubs cinemas and other
recreational activities open to people
outside of the upper classes its most
popular creation was the people's car
better known as the volkswagen which
further bridged the class divide since
it could be paid for in installments
in 1936 hermann goring was put in charge
of the economy beginning the four-year
plan which was supposed to make germany
entirely self-sufficient within four
years
unemployment virtually disappeared
conscription was instated and major
public works were undertaken most
famously the autobahn and the berlin
olympic games the most important part of
the four-year plan was that it saw the
beginning of german rearmament which was
a violation of the treaty of versailles
hitler's plan to unify the german people
picked up towards the end of the 30s in
1938 after some double dealing threats
and the referendum german troops marched
into austria and hitler announced its
annexation
after negotiations with the british and
the french it was agreed that germany
would annex the ethnically german
sudetenland from czechoslovakia
germany soon afterwards occupied half of
it which wasn't agreed the lithuanians
then caved into hitler's demands for
this territory
the british and the french afraid of a
new major war in europe did nothing to
deter hitler from seizing more and more
territory or re-army which served only
to embolden him an agreement was then
made between germany and the soviet
union to divide poland and on september
the 1st 1939 the germans invaded and two
weeks later
the soviets would do the same beginning
the second world war france and britain
had an agreement with poland and
declared war on germany although germany
would quickly overrun france
in 1941 the germans invaded the soviet
union shortly before declaring war in
the united states
two very bad ideas the germans were
initially very successful and by 1943
the third reich looked like this
the allies particularly the british in
the united states began bombing
campaigns against german cities
most notably cologne hamburg and of
course dresden these attacks were
designed to destroy german factories and
infrastructure as well as frighten the
germans into submission
the german economy didn't change
drastically at the beginning of the war
since germany had already been producing
arms for many years
one major difference between germany and
the allies was that germany was very
reluctant to have women working in the
factories which ultimately lowered the
number of available workers and
frontline soldiers
in the conquered territories the nazis
implemented a policy of forced labor in
poland many women were forced to work
farmlands to produce food whilst men
worked in factories many jewish people
alongside anyone else considered
undesirable were used for slave labor to
produce weapons some of which
they sabotaged throughout europe the
jewish populations were rounded up and
placed into concentration camps
the original purpose of these camps was
not extermination but forced labour
although they all had horrendous
mortality rates before and throughout
the war the nazis had attempted to
decide on what they would do with the
jewish population of europe
at first the nazis wished to deport them
and in fact some were sent to palestine
it wasn't until 1942 that the camps
began to explicitly exterminate
prisoners or that specialized
extermination camps were opened the best
known camps being auspitz and to blinker
where over one and a half million people
were killed between them
throughout the holocaust it is believed
that roughly five and a half million
jews were killed alongside roughly the
same amount of poles and soviet
prisoners
gypsies those with mental and physical
disabilities as well as homosexuals were
also exterminated alongside them having
failed to conquer the soviet union the
tide of the war changed against the
nazis and the soviets managed to force
them all the way back into germany
liberating many of the concentration
camps on the way
at the same time the united states
united kingdom of canada amongst others
invaded western europe and together they
managed to push the nazis back into
germany as well
most of the german high command
including hitler committed suicide in
april 1945 and germany surrendered in
may thus ending the third reich in the
nazi regime
germany was occupied and the surviving
nazi leaders were put on trial at
nuremberg where many were sentenced to
death after its surrender germany and
berlin were split into occupied zones
and both began the process of
denatification the allied
occupation zones were soon combined into
the federal republic of germany and the
soviet occupied zones became the german
democratic republic known as western
east germany respectively
they would remain divided until 1990 at
the end of the cold war
ultimately the legacy of nazi germany is
complex the nazis whilst committing
unimaginable crimes managed to
reinvigorate germany and build it into a
military powerhouse the nazis brought
about immense suffering across the
european continent and their actions
reduced many countries including germany
itself to ruins the consequences of
nazism are still being examined because
frankly it's still too soon to know
exactly what they are
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching